and so that's basically where we are
today we had this 30% shock to rinse to
get these lower pric to rent ratios up
to where the price will trigger new
building for this new landlord tenant
situation now as a first step those
families should just be owners they
should be able to just get the mortgage
and own those houses and they'd be
willing to pay a little more than the
landlords are because it's easier to be
a landlord to yourself but also a lot of
those families would just be living in
duplexes and apartment complexes and
high-rises downtown if we could build
those so and they'd be living when in
one in La instead of Phoenix if La got
off its trends of overregulation so
there's sort of several steps of housing
that we've been just regulating out of
existence to the point now where the
only thing left that we're capable of
allowing is institutionally owned single
family
HS all right guys bang bang I've got
Kevin here with me uh Kevin we are in
probably the single worst housing
affordability in the last 40 years or so
how did we get here
uh we got here by not building enough
houses for about 30 years
straight um and so yeah I think one of
the things that people tend to do is
they think of home home prices sort of
as
this uh this idea that's unrelated to
you know the fundamental if if we were
talking about stocks we'd be talking
about earnings and for some reason rent
uh just sort of gets forgotten in the
estimate of what's happening in housing
and uh housing is unaffordable because
the rents are high and the rents are
high because we haven't been building
enough houses it really is just supply
and demand uh equation is determining it
yep yeah completely to First
approximation 100% of it is rent now in
the first book that you wrote uh called
shutout you described uh something
called closed access cities and then
contagion cities and I thought maybe
that' be a good place to understand okay
why is where the houses are being built
so important as well yeah um yeah so I
you know this goes back to the to the
2000s bubble and bust and you know one
of the major sort of touchstones of my
work that that leads off to a different
path of analysis is there was a very
there's a very strong presumption that
there was an over you know a period of
excess and overbuilding uh by 2008 we
had this like excess of housing
inventory that we had to work
off and
uh and so that was really the first
thing that brought me into this space to
to to study this space and end up uh
writing two books and everything else is
discovering that really what was
happening back then was these localized
places it's a very distinct list it's
Boston New York City uh San Francisco LA
San Diego um I call those those are the
close access cities that just build far
fewer you know permit far fewer homes
than in the other major Metropolitan
including the r belt cities and so
really what happens is anytime you get
any sort of economic expansion or just
anything that would naturally sort of
increase people's demand for things
including housing there is no extra
housing in those cities if you think of
it in terms of a sort of a units per
capita if you can't add units and if
demand is sort of um or think of it as
people per unit maybe if if if demand is
um sort of well no units per s units per
capital is best if demand is sort of
increasing the units per capita if
everyone sort of consuming a little more
housing a little more square footage and
you know uh uh young adults moving out
sooner etc etc etc if units is fixed
then your capita has to go down and
literally that's what happens is these
cities have a have a counter cycal
migration pattern which was on steroids
back then uh tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of residents moving out of
those five cities into what you
mentioned as the contagion cities which
then was you know Phoenix and Las Vegas
and the Florida cities uh so really at
its base the the conventional wisdom was
upside down it was treated as this
period of excess and overb building when
really it was localized areas of
underbuilding like very distressed
underbuilding that actually created sort
of a refugee event um and the places
that looked like they were building in
excess were were just trying to keep up
with this migration event and they
couldn't uh and so they had what you
would conventionally call a bubble but
it's a bubble driven by demand that's
coming out of the places that have an
under Supply now since then what we've
done is sort of spread this shortage
Nationwide um and so we sort of have a
we've been underbuilding everywhere for
15 years now uh but you know you got a
little bit of that again with covid of
of people moving out of certain cities
and it was a sort of the contagion
cities were a slightly different set
this time it was the boes and Austin and
Phoenix is still part of that but um
yeah it's all driven by a lack of
housing which is creating these Mig this
these these cyclical migration events so
it it makes sense to me in terms of
going into the global uh financial
crisis and coming out of it uh this idea
of the closed access cities not enough
uh Supply therefore people got to go
somewhere else if they want to live they
move into the contagion cities people
are like oh here they come let's build a
bunch wait not as many of them showed up
because there's other kind of cyclical
events and now we've got over Supply and
under Supply in in the two different
types of cities you just said that for
15 years we've been underbuilding
nationally so not just closed access not
just conent cities but across the
country why is that been happening I
mean very simply I mean you can think of
it in terms of sort of categories of
Housing and we've sort of just been
making different categories illegal a
step at a time over the last 50 years so
first it was just generally in those
closed access cities uh you know there's
sort of a metropolitan area wide
obstruction to really all kinds of
housing um but you know at the core is
sort of this uh you know over the course
of the 20th century we sort of um uh
sort of put a put a an obstacle in front
of just the natural historic way that
cities developed you know you go to you
go to the the few places we have that
are true cities like downtown Chicago or
Manhattan um the building on the corner
is like the fifth thing that's been
there right it was a sheet Meadow then
it was a then it was a a cottage then it
was a a a large home then it was a
duplex and now it's a you know a
brownstone or something right or or a
high-rise um we basically over the
course of 20th century but a punch put a
bunch of zoning rules in place that said
cities can't develop anymore like they
used to uh once once somebody's there
that has enough political power they can
say okay this is what the city is going
to look like forever and it's an infront
to me if anything happens happens from
now on um and that you know that became
binding in those five cities but it's
but it was in the background of every
city and most of the other cities were
making up for it by building entry level
uh single family housing out in the
excerpts uh and effectively what we did
in 2008 is killed the entry level single
family home Market through mortgage
overregulation
um the uh the in fact that's really the
the first thing that brought me into
this topic was realizing back in
that that the market back in 2005 all
that supposed excess in mortgage lending
is a little bit it's greatly overstated
and sort of misstated that there wasn't
really a surge of lowincome owner
occupiers at the time uh but we but
that's the problem we tried to solve was
we tried to we we thought that was the
problem we basically regulated entry
level owner occupiers out of the
mortgage system that the average the
median credit score on a new mortgage
went from it had been 720 is for years
up until 2008 and then it went up to 760
and it's just been there ever since um
so effectively this Band-Aid that every
other city had on its housing Supply
which is we it's very hard to build
duplexes and apartment complexes
downtown and all that uh we ripped off
that Band-Aid by saying you know anybody
that would be buying a $250,000 new home
out on the outskirts of town can't get a
mortgage any anymore and we just killed
we that was that was more than a half
million units a year going into the
crisis and it just dissipated there just
that market went away so it really took
a decade for uh effectively we took the
owner occupiers out of that market they
had to eventually be replaced by
institutional buyers landlords and
renters and now you've got these
institutions buying build to rent
neighborhoods that are that are finally
um triggering new Supply and really that
the to trigger that Supply it really
took a decade of rents Rising enough to
get the price points back up to where
landlords want to build those houses
because it's still a condition where the
the owner occupiers can't get the
mortgages for them and so that's
basically where we are today is we had
this basically this 30% shock to rents
to get the price to rent R to get to get
these lower price to rent ratios up to
where the price will trigger new
building for this new landlord tenant uh
situ now those as a first step those
families should just be owners they
should be able to just get the mortgage
and own those houses and they'd be
willing to pay a little more than the
landlords are because it's easier to be
a landlord to yourself um but also a lot
of those families would just be living
in duplexes and and and apartment
complexes and highrises downtown if we
could build those so and they'd be
living in one in La instead of Phoenix F
La you know got off its um trends of of
overregulation so there's sort of
several steps of housing that that we've
been just regulating out of existence to
the point now where the only thing left
that that's that's that we're capable of
allowing is on the margin is uh is uh
institutionally owned single family
homes so this excess uh building like
the the fear of excess building really
and I think this is kind of a key
component to the second book that you
wrote uh building from the ground um why
are people so fearful like what are they
scared of for us to build more homes is
it like an aesthetic thing like in a San
Francisco they don't want to go above a
certain level is it a um overpopulation
like like what is the thing that is
driving the fear uh I mean as far as the
regulatory I mean there's sort of a an
investor macroeconomic fear of like of a
thinking that overbuilding was the cause
of 2008 and being afraid of of like the
market doing that again but in terms of
the locals that are actually creating
these regulations I mean I think it
really does just come down to that
Band-Aid that that um you know nobody
ever likes change there was always some
discomfort with with the with the
the uh you know fluctuations of of
development within a city there were
always um people that didn't like what
was going down at the
corner um and I think just you know the
automobile sort of allowed us to avoid
that discomfort for a
century because you know it's just a lot
less trouble to to build the place that
you know the the developers can get
approved to build that neighborhood out
in the excerts and so it get it gets
approved and I think we sort of just we
spent a a century sort of uh having
these political
um the sort of the the skill the
political skills to let us any change
sort of atrophy because we had this
Band-Aid in the erbs and the automobiles
that allowed us to get from those houses
to where we wanted to get uh and and
this just sort of built up over a
century and now all of a sudden
especially then when we pulled the
bandaid off in 2008 it's like oh we need
a way to build houses well we've spent a
century putting rules in place um that
we sort of could avoid dealing with uh
and of course there's now the yimi
movement you know there's a lot of
movement sort of to erase some of those
um uh developments and I think that'll
continue
um but you know I just think it's it's a
it's a matter of there being a slight
discomfort that sort of all of us share
when something's happening around us and
it was easy to sort of let the political
power the sort of the petty local
political power to to stop those
discomforts from happening to sort of
just Billow up and build up within our
political processes so now I think that
the political power sort of is a
mismatch of really the true um
discomfort but of course in that
negotiating process in the local
politics those discomforts get yelled
you know yelled at and and um
exaggerated and you know and so it seems
like a big deal right but for the most
part you know having the the the the the
forx down the road is really is not
actually going to ruin the neighborhood
you know now you mentioned the
institutional ownership of single family
homes kind of being like the end game
here uh if you listen to the peanut
gallery on the internet they will tell
you that like big bad you know large
financial institution is going to buy up
all the homes and then you will rent
everything you will own nothing and you
will be happy uh type uh Mantra um maybe
there is some truth to that obviously
they do own a lot of homes um what are
the pros and cons of institutional
ownership of uh single family homes in
America today's episode is brought to
you by trust and will I've gone through
a number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trustand will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp I
mean I I think it's it's I mean if you
compare it to say a small scale landlord
it's it's the traditional sort of pros
and cons you know there's some ways that
they're better they're more you know
that they really need to have some
reputation if they own thousands of
units and they and they don't want to
get a reputation as a as a landlord to
avoid um you know you have a lot more
variability and a lot less ability to
understand whether a a small scale
landlord is a good person that's going
to give you your deposit back or not you
know um so there's pluses and minuses
either way and there's all sorts of
studies about you know oh uh the institu
the large institutions evict people more
and that sort of stuff but I think those
differences are all really on the margin
and probably don't matter that much in
the big picture um I do think for the
most part it's a it's a big it's a big
con to have uh to to be if especially if
you're a long-term resident you should
own the place you live in it doesn't
make sense to to have a landlord
relationship in that mix um but I think
the mistake people make is thinking that
it's the institutions coming in that
that that's really more of an effect
than a cause the cause is that we took
10 or 20 or 30 million households and
decided in 2008 they weren't qualified
to get a mortgage anymore even though
they had been for decades and they
really didn't have that much to do with
what happened in 2008 so um you know
what I find um uh a little bit
frustrating is that uh that you know
there's it's sort of a
misidentification to say that these that
these institutions are they driving up
the prices and whatnot the the core
issue is that those families can't get
mortgages and the people that complain
about the private equity and the big
institutions are are generally just
totally uh incurious about the about
this probably the biggest political um
uh act to take place in Generations
which was D you know locking those
families out of the mortgage Market no
nobody
really seems to have no care or really
have noticed that it happened because it
happened in the in the chaos of the
crisis um but really you know part of my
work is sort of pulling the data that
the the the evidence from the data that
you can really see that closing down
those mortgage markets um had a
tremendous effect on on real estate
values after 2008 there was this late
collapse in workingclass uh neighborhood
home values that clearly was a result of
this tightening of of lending that
really uh matter is a lot more than the
stuff that was happening in the closed
access of the content cities um places
from Dallas to Atlanta to you know every
city across the country whether they had
a bubble or not the low end loses 10 20
30% compared to the high end after 2008
because we did this policy decision on
mortgage regulation uh really was it's
just a a a nuclear bomb in the middle of
working class balance sheets and really
just no nobody even knows that it
happened
given what you said so far my conclusion
is that uh how to solve housing
affordability is to build more housing
if that is correct um how do we
determine what type of housing where and
who should be building it seems to be a
big question as well how do you think
about those three
things I mean I think we just have to
make the market work so you know that in
theory um in theory you would like to
have
municipalities um
sort of planning out how that's going to
develop there's two problems with that
the first problem is that it you know
the we're really talking about a
metropolitan area like each metropolitan
area is sort of a an entity you know
there's the commuter Zone really defines
what's going to happen and you can't you
when you divide that up into these
municipalities that all have their
little part of the metro area um there's
just no way that they can govern um that
planning process proc so what happens is
they all sort of become little fums of
uh trying to ensure that they're not the
part of town that that declines in
socioeconomic status uh and so what
happens is you just get sclerosis
throughout the market of of everyone
making it illegal to build anything that
might bring in families that have a
slightly different socioeconomic status
than the ones that are there and I think
that problem still would exist even at
the Metro Area
level um even if we did fix that
governance problem so you know I'd like
to think that there is a potential for
careful planning but a hundred years of
of um experience says we just aren't
capable of doing it well and actually at
the point we are now Anarchy is an
improvement Anarchy is probably not uh
optimal but it's better than what we've
where we've come to um so you know
there's a lot of people that work on the
politics of it and that's not really uh
uh my focus uh but it does sort of help
to drive my um my project to realize
that really there's nothing we could do
that's worse than what we're than what
we're doing
now when we think about um inside some
of these dense cities one of the uh
areas that I probably have the most uh
familiarity with is in New York City uh
maybe in the mid
2010s uh there was a lot of foreign
buyers that were coming to the market
Market they were buying up uh Apartments
but mainly kind of luxury type
apartments and in talking to people in
the market they were like oh here comes
all this money we need to build right
and we need to be able to satisfy that
demand similar to your idea of closed
access cities and contagion cities um
and people never kind of showing up in
full force to the contagion cities uh
there was Capital controls in some of
these foreign countries including places
like China and so when the buildings
finally got built and the inventory came
online it almost feel like there's a
bifurcation in the luxury Market there
is much more Supply available and some
of these units will sit for very long
periods of time but New York City rents
are at all-time highs because the kind
of lower part of the market is actually
uh the the opposite imbalance right
there's way more demand than there is uh
Supply and so how do you think about
maybe the bifurcation of luxury versus
non-luxury in some of these cities yeah
really that's at the heart of the model
that I use of the substack is is that I
have a series of papers that I put out
through the Marcus Center um and if if
you go to my substack the the little uh
menus across the top of the research
button is where you can see links to
those papers and really what the the
motto I developed uh just by sort of
looking at the um Trends in home prices
and seeing what was different about the
closed access cities versus other cities
is that
um when you when you have an pmic
shortage of
housing uh I think sort of the the basic
understanding of what's happening within
the metropolitan area can be thought of
as just that the natural
um elasticity of demand for low-income H
uh Families versus high income
families and um you know you could think
of it in terms at the low-end housing is
a necessity and you know that what we
call housing is a basket of all sorts of
things that actually are a part of what
you're buying with housing there's the
actual walls in the ceilings you know
they're staying dry in a rainstorm
having a place to sleep a place to make
your meals there's you know neighborhood
character people like to live around uh
people that are wealthier than they are
uh in a nice School District uh with a
park
nearby
um uh you know uh access to amenities
you know there's all these sorts of
things
that are a part of that basket and so
you start with staying dry and cooking
your meals but all that other stuff is
sort of you know that's a necessity and
everything else that you're adding is
sort of a luxury but it's all part of a
basket of what is housing right and so
at the high end it's it's mostly luxury
that that Foreigner buying the penthouse
suite in Manhattan um and demand for
luxuries is is elastic if you if you
have less money you're just going to go
without it it's not not a big deal right
and as you move down to the lowend where
it's a necessity then demand becomes
inelastic you know I'm trying to to hang
on to the job and the family I have in
LA and if rents go up another you know
I'm sort of at the at the location
that's the least I can put up with and
the rents go up another 10% what am I
going to do but pay pay the 10% right so
you get this natural gradient of demand
behavior from top to bottom and so what
happens is when you have an endemic lack
of Supply at the top it's it's almost
not noticeable like uh I have X amount
of dollars it's normal for a person with
my amount of dollars to spend this
amount on housing and in this city that
gets you a 2,000 foot condo uh you know
on on Fifth Avenue or something right
and so that's what you get and that you
know it's not like you're you're uh
nashing your teeth and and rending your
garments that you didn't get an extra
thousand square feet right so so you
naturally actually compromise on the
real housing the amount of housing you
get right and as you move down Market um
uh you don't change how much housing you
get you just pay the extra price and so
what happens is you get this
systematic uh sort of substitutions that
all go downward where you start at the
top and and there's not the 3,000 foot
condo that you would have available in
Atlanta or Dallas and so you literally
like trade down neighborhoods right you
trade into it you buy into a
neighborhood that's a lower
socioeconomic status than you would have
been in Atlanta or Dallas that means
there's less units available in that
neighborhood for the people that would
normally live there right so they have
to trade down and and that trading down
like builds up as you move down the the
you know the stock of housing within the
metropolitan area and it really creates
this distinctive
systematic uh um picture where we in
cities where you don't have enough
housing the rents and the prices go up
the most at the the low end and then and
then related to that is you you you
always have more uh out migration from
that City from the low end eventually it
gets to the point where they don't have
options left and some family on the
margin moves away from the city
entirely so so where you have a supply
problem you it's like a canver um you
know at the top end the prices really
don't change that much because
everyone's just changing their their
consumption and the prices are and rinse
systematically go up at the low end so a
lot of times what people do is they do
analysis where they look at the median
price of homes in a in a city um and
what's uh what I have found is that
really the median doesn't mean anything
except that it's halfway to the bottom
right so the median house in LA or New
York City is expensive but it's only
expensive because it's a part it's
halfway in this process to you know the
price down here that it takes to get
somebody to move out of the city
entirely um and so that's really a way
you can tell the difference between an
LA and an Austin is in Austin they don't
have this indemic supply problem and but
Austin was a contagion city um uh you
know in this in the postco period so in
Austin prices went like this right they
went up and down everywhere because it
was just this migration Surge and it
wasn't this systematic behavior that
comes from a lack of Supply uh so you
can you can really tell the difference
between a housing a temporary housing
boom and an endemic shortage because in
a city you know if you're looking at zip
code incomes here and prices in a in a
city that's just having a boomman bus
like Phoenix in 2005 or Austin in
2020 it goes like this but in a city
like LA or New York City it goes like
this actually it's just in those cities
now it's just stuck like this and
actually it's just a process of people
moving into neighborhoods and people
getting kicked out the bottom moving to
the other places and so they're just
stuck at this level
uh where it's it's more it's almost more
of a flow issue when you're looking at
home prices in the housing market in
those cities of just households
basically flowing out getting priced out
through Rising rents and prices um so
yeah that's that's fundamentally at the
core of how I analyze cities to know
what's going on there now when we see um
the home builders especially the ones
that are publicly traded I think that
gives us the best sense in terms of you
know where are they going what are doing
um do you glean any data from them in
terms of potentially are we solving the
problem like are they going to just ramp
up building and you know we talk in five
years and we're like all right we
recognize that we underbuilt now we're
building enough and and we get out of
the problem or is the message maybe a
little bit more dire and it's like look
there really isn't any sort of data
point or sign that we're headed in the
right direction
now uh you know there's there's sort of
multif family and there's single family
and multif family is a lot more uh you
know private equity and reats and and
you know these sort of uh distributed uh
institutions that you know build a
project at a time um and I would say
that part of the market is just has just
been hitting its regulatory peak in
terms of just um you know I think we
we've been hitting 400,000 units a year
or so that basically just it's because
they're all waiting at the perit office
to get permission for that next unit and
that's basically just happening in
cities across the country
so I think that will slowly loosen up as
the M political movement gains ground um
but it's really a political question now
as far as the public home builders that
are building single family home
neighborhoods I think that's a really
interesting space because um they have
really been um uh uh Supply constrained
in the covid era and so um if you look
at
completions since
2019 single family home completions it's
basically a straight
line now what happened
is co hit and everyone didn't know what
was going to happen at first and then
all of a sudden there was this housing
boom and sales went way up and when
sales went way up basically all the uh
buyers you know they bought up all the
finished units that were setting you
know the sort of normal amount of
inventory that was sitting there they
bought all that up they bought up all
the units under construction and then
for a year year and a half um the supply
the covid related Supply issue really
prevented us from actually meeting
demand so really for about a year and a
half what was happening is the buyers
were sort of paying a premium to to be
put in a Queue at the back of the line
for a house that wasn't going to be be
built any faster than if they had
weren't buying it um because there was
no inventory the the builders were going
to build it but if you're willing to pay
us an extra 10% we'll put your name on
it it's still going to take an extra
extra three months to build compared to
what it used to but your name's in the
queue um and that really was what was
happening during the inflationary period
um and so what happened is eventually
when the inflationary period stopped and
everything leveled out sales declined
quite a bit people tend to view that as
like a normal
cyclical um uh you know ups and downs
but really uh the reduction in sales was
just the of this uh you know negotiation
to put you in the queue the sales really
never declined past you know below the
point where we can complete houses
anyway we the the home builders are
still at capacity and they're going to
be at capacity in a year and they're not
they they haven't had any trouble
selling finished homes and they're not
going to have any trouble selling
finished homes um so we're not really at
the like the bottom of a sales uh
collapse we we're at the end of this
very unique period And as far as I can
tell it's never happened before in
American housing markets where home
builders literally just didn't
have uh units to sell um and weren't
going to so I think it looks bearish if
you look at that Trend that downtrend in
um sales but really the home builders
are basically at the top end of a normal
Mark what would normally be a normal
market and I think from here we're just
going to see actually a very boring a as
those covid Supply constraints get
worked out and they can get Transformers
into the to the electrical um
infrastructure to open the neighborhood
and get the windows in and everything
else that's been uh delaying uh
construction um then we're just going to
glide into back into a growth growth in
completions and sales are just going to
follow along with that I
think now there's two other topics I
want to talk about before I let you go
uh the first is politics second is the
Federal Reserve Federal Reserve is not a
political organization uh unless you
talk to some people and they they may
think so so maybe we'll start there um
the Federal Reserve loose monetary
policy I think a lot of people say uh
you know drove immense rises in prices
uh of both real estate but also you know
higher inflation Etc and uh that's the
cause of some of this how much Credence
do you put to the Federal Reserve kind
of contribution to housing affordability
or the lack thereof uh or is that maybe
an easy lazy excuse and it's really not
as uh intense of an involvement this
episode is brought to you by cal.com
what do I have in common with Chad
Hurley from YouTube Toby from Shopify
and Alexis from 776 and the co-founder
of Reddit we all use cal.com instead of
cly and we are all early investors as
well cal.com is leading the charge of
scheduling Platforms in the open-source
sphere offering you the chance to
harness the efficiency previously
reserved for Le corporations and Tech
gurus if you like to have your calendar
organized and be able to have an
efficient exchange when scheduling but
you love all of the benefits of open-
source technology then cal.com is for
you they are transforming sophisticated
calendar management into an accessible
tool for all via a userfriendly
interface you can customize it and you
can make your calendar work for you use
code pomp for $500 off when you set up
your team with cal.com today again go to
cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an
open-source tool that allows you to take
back control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your time yeah I I
am definitely a uh have a I suppose
you'd call it a heterodox view on that
um I don't think the FED really has had
anything to do with uh housing
affordability and price trends over the
last year three years five years 40
years um so as a uh I'll I'll start say
in the two in the in the 2010s there's
you know the Zer the Z zero interest
rate policy that um gets um a lot of
gruff um and um what I say is uh Zur
wasn't a p it wasn't a policy the
natural interest rate was uh was low uh
mortgage rates are what mortgage rates
are because the Market's put has put
them there partly because
we locked 20 million families out of
mortgage market so there's no demand for
mortgages um and so you know in building
from the ground up I go that that's the
book that's really about sort of the
timeline of the of the um of the
financial crisis and initially um when
um when the fed started a QE it was
actually because they were trying to
keep the target interest rate at 2% and
it was so far above neutral that in Ben
bank's memoral he says if they hadn't
started doing QE where effectively
initially what QE was was basically
borrowing cash back from the banks
instead of printing it um because they
were trying to maintain their 2% uh
Target which they never could actually
hit um uh
the the the FED went to 0% screaming and
kicking they actually created a crisis
trying not to um so the initial drop to
0% interest rates was certainly not a
fed policy and in fact had they dropped
uh rates to 0% when they should have we
might not have had a crisis um and it's
not the the period since then isn't that
different like the the the low rates are
the rates are low because the p as as
Milton free used to say low interest
rates aren't a sign of current loose
policy they're a sign of past tight
policy and that's basically where we've
been for 15 years um so I just wouldn't
I wouldn't attribute any of the stuff
that was happening in housing preco to
the fed the the the the Fed was we were
at zero because zero is the market rate
um and uh home prices weren't High
because mortgages were low because you
can explain high home prices with with
high rents and if we were over
simulating housing for the last 40 years
surely you'd expect to get a little bit
of rent relief from that but we've seen
the opposite for 40 years so um so I
just don't attribute anything to to Fed
policy and in terms of the postco period
I'm fully on team transitory the in the
inflation was International it was due
to these Supply constraints um you know
I suppose we could have uh uh sucked
every dollar out of the economy and and
um and you know used um uh gold bars and
and clamshells to buy things with but I
don't think that would have made us any
better off uh I don't think the FED
should have tried to lower you know it
was inflation that came about from other
reasons not not really from them over
stimulating and they had no business
trying to reverse it and in fact that
inflation reversed before um any
significant uh um uh interest rate uh
increases happened so
uh as of um you know the last real
above uh ex you know excess month of of
inflation was June
2022 um where I I like to look at CPI
inflation without the shelter component
for a number of reasons um and it's
actually much higher in the summer of
2022 without the sh because the shelter
comp has this this lag because the way
they measure it through survey data um
so if you take this shelter component
out Jun June 22 it's it's like 14%
inflation and then July it's back to
basically 2% and it's been 2% since you
know for 18 months since then um in June
2022 the fed target rate is like a
percent in a quarter and there there's
just there's no it's
implausible that you could reverse 14%
inflation with one and a quarter perc
Target rate uh you know uh
nobody back in vul's day nobody would
have said that oh he's he's increased
the target rate to per in the quarter
the 70s are over now right uh if it's
truly monetary inflation they would have
needed to raise rates to 10 or 15%
inflation dropped because it was
transitory it had nothing to do with
them and actually they did a great thing
by not trying to reverse it which
actually ended up raising long-term
rates and so really what I think the FED
mostly did is chased those long-term
rates up which is great the long-term
rates Rose because sentiment improved um
and there's a lot of pint up uh uh
production potential because of all
these covid Supply constraints that
we've been dealing with so um so I think
I think the Fed was actually pretty
loose in mid 2022 which was which was
exactly what we want them to be because
now we didn't get a deflation when when
that transitory inflation dropped
because the fed's been loose I think
that probably helped keep inflation
above zero right now and um and so you
know I do think they need to lower rates
a little bit going forward and of course
we've seen a shift in the last month or
so of of expectations moving that way so
I eventually they'll get back to three
or 4% and we'll have a nice upward
sloping yield curve and and um yeah I I
think J pal has been
fantastic the uh the last question I
have is around Paul politics many of the
cities that you uh described um in terms
of these uh closed access cities uh I
think the narrative online is they're
Democrat controlled you know they have
very kind of destructive policies um
whether that is true or not um on those
specific cities uh how do you think
politics plays into this and and is one
political party maybe more to blame or
or their policies tend to create or help
of the
situation uh yeah you know the housing
issue is sort of funny because it's very
it it doesn't it doesn't map to the
normal left right um uh you know um map
that we use there there's yimes and
nimes on both ends of the extreme uh I I
think you know I used to be sort of more
of a like oh the progressives are you
know Hypocrites and they're ruining the
cities with
but I you know there are natural um
stresses that come from Urban living
that you know when when we're all in
close quarters it is a city is a hard
thing to manage and I think it tends to
lend itself
to um you know to more uh more blue Pol
you know politics than than a small City
or rural area does because you end up
with all these you know
um relational things you have to deal
with between classes and between
neighborhoods and between you know
because everyone's in close quarters um
uh and and a lot of you know problems
with with um public benefits or crime
you know sort of lend themselves to a
communal um politics um so I'm not sure
that I I think sort
of cities are where this problem is a
problem we have to deal with and it just
so happens that cities tend to be more
blue um and so the the blue politicians
are there where the problem is
difficult
um uh but you know you certainly it you
know it it's irritating to see some of
the you know sort of um uh hypocritical
uh you know anti-market rhetoric that
you see in the cities uh you know sort
of pretending to be for the for the poor
families when really the policies just
the the deao policies are to just make
it impossible to build housing at all
that at the end of the day leads to this
migration within the city that basically
leads to all the poor families moving
out so um it's certainly the the the
progressives in those cities certainly
um uh are good at playing that sort of
hypocritical pay yourself on the back
game while they make sure nobody of
lower socioeconomic status is ever going
to move
there where can we send people to find
your books or find you online if they
want to learn more about this or engage
uh further with these
ideas um at at Twitter uh I'm at K Erman
it's k a r d m Ann uh is my uh is my
handle there uh the substack is Kevin .s
substack
do.com um and it's called the urman
housing
tracker uh and
then uh um the two books are shut shut
out which shut out is sort of a sort of
sets the background like uh you know
here's what here's all the ways that a
shortage of
housing uh is affecting our
economy and sort of a big part of that
is that it created this boom and bust
cycle in the
2000s uh and then I sort of tease that
in shut out and then building from the
ground up is more of the timeline of
walking through th those events with
this with these different uh you know
colored glasses on in terms of thinking
of it as being a housing shortage
instead of housing uh bubble um and so
yeah both of those are and I I would say
the shut out's probably a little more
academic whereas building from the
ground UPS I think a little more
accessible in terms of the the writing
um and you could think of shutout as uh
sort of it's sort of the microeconomics
and and um building from the ground up
is sort of sort of the macroeconomics um
of the of Housing and the economy over
the last 20 years um so yeah that's
that's where that's where people can
find me I I highly suggest people go
read the books and uh subscribe to your
substack you do a fantastic job talking
about the housing market and I've
learned a lot so uh thank you so much
for all the time energy effort that goes
into uh into all the work and we
definitely do this again in the future
great yeah I'd love to thanks